- Please join me in welcoming Barbara Grosz.
- Thanks very much for that
wonderful introduction.
It's really a great honor to be here
giving a keynote at Faculty Summit
where the theme is focused on AI at the Edge.
It's a time where it's really important
for those of us doing research in AI
to think about what
capabilities systems have,
what our methods can do,
what they can't do,
where the challenges are
and what we may be
doing in the future.
And for everyone in computer science
to think about how we can design systems
that actually do good in the world,
and don't do harm.
This is perhaps, this is Turing's
best-known conjecture
about building machines
with intelligence.
And by the way he equated
intelligence with thinking.
He thought they were, he wasn't talking
about intelligence as being able to do research
that gets a Nobel Prize.
So his most well-known conjectures
are about what he called
being able
to participate
well in the imitation game,
now talked about
as passing the Turing test.
That conjecture, that we would have machines
able to do that by the year 2000 was not realized.
But the conjecture that you see on this slide was.
People now regularly talk about machines
as though they were thinking.
Of course, they frequently also ask
what were they thinking,
when they do things
that don't make sense.
So about five years ago, when we were celebrating
the 100th anniversary of Turing's birth,
I was asked to give a talk
at a Turing symposium,
and I was trying to figure out
what I could say that was novel,
because people have talked about
Turing and written about Turing.
And I decided it would be interesting to think
about if Turing were with us now,
I mean there are people
who live to 100 years.
If he were with us now, what would he be
Just to the people watching the clock.
This clock is wrong.
I am not four minutes over.
So you might want to reset it.
OK.
They didn't hear me.
I'll try to keep to my time without the clock.
OK so, and of course no one knows
what Turing would say.
They got it.
But I thought the world had changed a lot
and I wanted to put a challenge to the AI community.
I hoped that other people would also do that,
so I still welcome other challenges.
And this is the challenge that I came up with.
And it's really important to notice
that this is about working
as a team member over the long term,
not one-shot deals;
not just one question,
one answer,
we can do that just fine.
And I also want to say, it says here that
you won't notice that it's not human.
It's not to say that the systems would be
indistinguishable from humans,
it's fine to know you're working
with a computer system.
But it has to behave sensibly.
So I'll give you an example from healthcare.
A smart partner that searches documents much faster
than any human being could do,
if it delivers sensible results,
passes the test.
If it delivers nonsense it doesn't.
OK why now?
Because AI has really
made it out into the world.
The focus in this meeting, the descriptions
of the focus of this summit
all make it very clear
that we now have AI
capabilities entering daily life.
So we really ought to think about how the systems
we're building are going to work with people.
Another thing that's happened,
as AI technologies have made it into the world,
we see widespread investments in AI,
we see lots of claims about them.
We see lots of fantasies, not only
that you can let your car drive
while you play games or watch movies.
Don't do it.
We're not there yet.
But also in healthcare, in elder care, in education.
And it is crucial as we think about this
to think not simply about the systems,
but about the people
that they interact with.
And of course, we also have a lot of nightmares.
I will say the nightmares are not new.
People have been thinking about building machines,
could a human being build a machine,
create something that could think?
That was like a person?
For centuries.
It goes back at least
to the Golem of Prague.
Certainly to Frankenstein.
And more recently we have things
like the movie Ex Machina.
So on the one hand, this android dream
set a context for Turing's conjecture.
On the other hand, it makes clear
that there has, at least in western culture,
it's very different in Japan, by the way,
they think of robots as cuddly.
And I'll leave it as a question for you
to think about the cultural part.
So my argument is, if we want to get away
from the philosophical focus,
and Turing was asking
a philosophical question.
And away from the science fiction
of machines gone mad to get real intelligent behavior,
we need to think
about building machines
that augment our capabilities.
Not that replace us
or replicate human intelligence.
So here's my quip.
We know how to replicate
human intelligence.
The process is known
to be fun.
The product is babies.
Even when they grow up,
they have only human intelligence.
We don't need to build machines
that have more of that, we need to build machines
that complement that.
And I'm going to very quickly
talk about five reasons
why we want to aim
for coordination and teamwork now.
The first two are about how
times have changed since Turing.
Then about our responsibilities.
And then because we're doing research,
we want to do exciting research.
So that's how people use computers.
In Turing's day, one person, one machine.
Now we have many people,
in many places, in many systems, working at many times.
There are several arguments
from the cognitive sciences,
I'll just say
a couple briefly.
Brain development.
We know that in the first
two years of life if you don't have social interaction,
your brain is smaller
and it generates less energy.
And you're basically cooked for life if you don't have
that social interaction in time.
We also know that language
learning depends on interpersonal interaction.
There's some wonderful work
by Patricia Kuhl at the University of Washington.
I'll give you one example.
She looked at babies, American babies,
no exposure to Mandarin.
Looking at the issue, so we're all born,
for those who don't know,
we're all born able
to recognize the phonemes
of all languages in the world.
By the time we're 12 months old,
we know only the phonemes of the languages
that we've been exposed
to in those first 12 months.
Somewhere between eight
and 10 months of age,
English-speaking babies
understand the difference
between L and R,
and Japanese-speaking babies
have lost that distinction.
Many other examples.
She compared exposing babies
between 8 and 10 months to American babies,
to a speaker of Mandarin
face-to-face and watching
that same person on video.
The Mandarin phonemes were retained by the babies
who had the face-to-face interaction,
not by the ones
watching the video.
OK what about engineering?
Well, if we want to build good systems,
we have to think about the people
that we're building systems for
and how their different
cognitive processes work.
I'll come back to language later
in the talk, but here's an example
to illustrate getting things wrong.
I asked my phone, I won't say which one,
where's the nearest gas station?
I've got a list of 16.
I asked which ones were open, and it offered to search
the web for the phrase
which ones are open,
which would have not have
gotten me the answer I wanted.
OK.
I think it's really important
for all of us building systems
to focus on the errors
the systems make,
rather than bragging about
the great successes that they have,
because the errors are telling us
where there's a mismatch
with our expectations.
The same thing is true of Watson jeopardy,
and I hear that is now proving true
of deep learning systems
with captioning of images.
So look for the errors to understand
where there's a mismatch.
Finally there's an ethical argument
for considering working with people.
Autonomous vehicles give a lot of promise,
the potential is huge.
I'm very excited about them.
But they have to be able to work
with us, otherwise they're going to run into trouble
and we've already
seen many of that.
As wonderful as the cars are,
because we don't do what they expect.
But hey, we're here first,
we're building them for us.
People are a pain in the neck.
How many people here have tried
to do experiments with people?
Really, we don't behave very well.
But too bad.
You got to deal with them.
And finally, there are all of these
really wonderful scientific challenges.
So, let's go for it.
I've listed some here.
There are many, many more.
The last one is actually
about the challenge of designing experiments
that let us know
how people work.
OK.
So I want to shift now
from the argument for thinking about this,
to thinking about
the research.
There are many domains
in which this challenge arises,
many kinds of teamwork.
I'm going to mention those and then
I'm going to talk about some of my own work
in developing foundations.
Theoretical foundations for modeling teamwork,
and then putting those to use.
So education, health care,
writing papers, driving.
We can think about groups of people
and groups of systems,
groups of people
that systems help.
The last two on this slide,
autonomous system,
human collaborations
and crowd work present
really interesting challenges
where we as people can
teach machines to do better.
But we have to design them
so that they'll learn from us,
and so that we're
teaching them things
that are interesting,
not making up,
not doing boring things
because they are stupid.
OK.
So shift to talking
about some work.
There are several different theories
of collaboration that have been developed.
I'm going to talk about mine
because it has some features
I think are really important.
But all of them have mostly the
features I'm going to talk about.
So the first thing to note about
building systems that can be team members
is you have to design the team
work from the start,
and you'll see that
in the formalism
that I show you.
And it's partly because teamwork is not
simply the sum of individual plans.
You can't take my plan to do something
and Eric's plan to do something individually
and just smoosh them together.
And you'll see that now in the theory
that I'm going to talk about.
So this is all in English.
It was actually developed
as a formal theory in logic.
I'm going to talk about this
as I give you these principles.
I want you to understand this is not just soft,
blah, blah, blah.
But in fact, if any one of these principles
doesn't hold for a system,
you can show it
will fail at teamwork
at some point in time.
So first we need each team member to
commit to the team doing its job.
That commitment is framed
as an intention, which means that you have to believe
that the team
can actually do the work.
You have to reach consensus on how
you're going to go about doing it,
and on who you're going
to allocate subtasks to.
Now that doesn't mean that everybody,
in fact it importantly
doesn't mean that everybody
has to know everything
about what everyone else is doing.
But you need to know about the points of join,
so not all the details.
Just with this much you can see
that there is a requirement
that the group have some decision
making processes.
They know when they've come to an agreement,
and that they have mutual belief
of the decisions that they have.
So we all have to know what we're all doing.
In addition, two things that I'm going to illustrate
with some examples of research
are that we have to commit
to the tasks that we're given.
And again, that commitment is an intention
and you can't commit to something you can't do.
That you know you can't do.
So our systems cannot commit
to doing things they can't do.
You also have to commit to each other's success,
which means that you have to try to,
the systems have to be able to, when they act,
think about whether they are helping us
get our jobs done or interfering.
OK.
So that's the delegation challenges.
We're going to talk about three different roles
for these theoretical frameworks.
First, system specification, then design guide,
and then as an analytic framework.
And I hope that you'll take away from this
that not only are these roles,
but for each of these roles
there are different ways
you could implement the system.
So you could use machine learning or Bayesian
reasoning or gridding theory or logical rules.
It's the properties that the theory says the system
has to have that you need to get into the system
within whatever implementation
you're going to use.
I want to read you a quote from Yao Shou
in a recent CACM article, when he was talking
about the usefulness
of logically solid theories.
He said, "This matters because it helps you build
software that's beautiful on the inside,
and if the internal structure isn't right,
if it doesn't cohere
with how humans think of the world,
you'll never have a truly
beautiful user experience."
So I hope you'll keep that in mind.
OK, so first theory as system specification.
And I'm going to talk about the problem
of interruption management.
So the shared plan principle here
is that you have to commit to each other's success.
So if you're going to interrupt somebody,
you ought to have information that's valuable to them,
to interrupt only when it's useful.
How many of you have been interrupted by dialog boxes
warning you of things like your battery dying
in three hours
that you don't really care about now?
OK.
So just go forward without me?
There we go.
So there are two insights that we had about
the interruption management problem,
and these are insights from A.J.
Comar's PhD dissertation work.
A.J.
is here now.
The first of these is that when we are
collaborating, most of the time,
most of what
we're doing is individual.
Remember, we break the tasks down into subtasks,
we delegate to other people.
And if we take advantage of that
in your composability we can get computational savings.
The second insight is that we have
to have efficient ways of reasoning
about each other's activities,
even when we don't know in detail
what other people are doing.
So let me look at the first.
This is work on seeing
that the problem can decompose
into individual actions
and joint actions, and then A.J.
designed a formalism which he called
nearly decomposable MDPs.
The idea is you're maximizing
a joint function, but you have independent,
individual and joint
action sets,
and you decouple the transitions
depending on whether
there's a dependency,
when you need to communicate,
or things are independent.
The result of this is that you get
exponential efficiencies in computation time.
You can actually compute things
you couldn't compute,
if you try to do it fully,
as a fully coordinated system.
OK.
Second, the second problem... oops!
This is running ahead of me.
OK.
I have this fear
it's on automatic advance.
OK.
So that's an example where there's
a specification that you commit to each other's success
and therefore
that you don't interrupt
when you don't have something useful.
The second example I want to use is work
on what we've called collaborative interfaces,
and this is in
an educational setting.
Here the domain challenge
is we have lots of interesting,
exploratory software for kids
in schools to learn
math and science
and evidence shows that
by exploring on their own,
they learn more than
just being lectured at.
The constraint that we get
from shared plans in designing these interfaces,
is that you can't assign something
to the computer system
that it isn't
capable of doing.
So the task allocation, so we looked at,
could we build interfaces that would help teachers
where we leave with the teachers
the things that they do best;
so having broad
knowledge of students
and how to interact with them.
But assign to the computer recognizing patterns
and what the students are doing.
And I'll give you
two examples of this.
On the left you see
an exploratory system for teaching middle school
students probability
and statistics.
So what happens
when you flip a coin?
And on the right you see a system
for teaching freshmen chemistry.
What we did in this work was to expand
on plan recognition algorithms,
the plan recognition algorithms
that had been developed in AI
up to this point
were all algorithms
that assumed that
we were well-behaved.
Eighth grade children,
given exploratory software,
not only make
mistakes sometimes,
that's part of it,
so you have to look for things
that are not right and don't fit.
But they also like playing
around and exploring in ways
that maybe the designers of the system
or the designers
of the problems hadn't thought.
So the plan recognition algorithm had to deal
with those kinds of errant behaviors.
And the result was that we developed
new plan recognition algorithms.
So this is a place where taking
on the challenge of building
something that worked well with people,
we actually came up
with hard scientific problems.
These systems were both validated off line
by through surveys of teachers
and finding out
how well they worked,
and also proving
correctness of algorithms.
One of the most interesting responses
for me happened after the summit a few years ago.
There was a workshop on AI
and education,
and the chemistry
faculty member at CMU
who had developed virtual labs
said the interesting thing for him
was that he learned from the system
how his students
were solving problems
and it wasn't the way
he thought they were.
So this is part of what a system
can do to really help in education.
But notice, we're not replacing the teacher;
we're complementing the teacher.
More recently, Coby Gaule,
who's at Ben-Gurion University
who worked on S-Cast
and then did virtual labs,
has been working
So this was plan recognition
in a very different domain,
teaching seventh grade geometry
where the students
are working in small groups,
and they're chatting
with each other.
Again, the teacher can't listen
in on all the conversations,
and the technical question was,
could you detect
critical moments
in those student conversations
and alert the teacher to groups
that needed to be encouraged
to do something else?
You can't do full
natural language processing, it's not just dialogue,
it's multiple students
talking at once at once.
But they could use machine learning
to detect those critical moments.
And they've just done some early
classroom validations
that show that when you are using the software,
the teachers are actually intervening
at better moments
and the duration
of interventions
is more appropriate
for what they are,
because they're not trying to do
too many things at once.
OK.
So the third thing
that I want to look at,
my current research on
healthcare coordination.
And this is where we use shared plans
not for system design, at least not yet.
And not in a system specification way,
but to look at what was going wrong
in health care coordination.
So the setting is clinics for children
with complex conditions.
This could be from genetic problems, it could be
from birth problems,
it could be from illness
at an early age.
The children see somewhere
between 10 and 15 care providers.
No human being can keep
track of 14 other people.
Some of us try,
but it's really not possible.
So the domain challenge here is,
could we build a computer system
that would assist
the care providers
in keeping track of what
each other is doing?
I'll just make a note that electronic
heath records does nothing to help with this problem.
They may exacerbate it and I'll
give you an example in a minute.
So this little sketch just shows you
how much communication goes on in different modalities
among people on a typical team.
You can feel very sorry
for the PCP in the middle,
who is like the quarterback and worse
with no technology to help him.
OK, what we learned
from looking at the work that people were doing was
that this was a very
different kind of teamwork
from the tightly coupled teamwork
we had studied before
and that our theories
had originally covered,
and that our plan recognition
algorithms were working in.
So the first thing is the team
is relatively flat.
The PCP might be in the middle of things,
but he's not in charge
and he can't dictate
to other people what to do.
They're also loosely coupled, which means
that they're like the nearly de-coupled plan.
Sorry I'm not pushing the button.
It's just working.
It's autonomous.
I don't know how it became like that.
It is not collaborating well with me.
Like, I'm not there yet,
and I'm not running out of time yet.
OK.
So the bottom line here is,
we have a new kind of teamwork.
What we did before will not work.
So the first thing we did, having observed
this by looking at what people,
the care providers
are doing, by talking to
Oh wait, I forgot
this really great quote.
Sorry I have to go back to this, because it shows you
one of the things that for me
or the graduate student
working on this learned from,
asked the physicians
that she interviewed was,
was there ever a time
that they couldn't find the information
they needed in the electronic health record.
Here's my favorite example.
Answer: there isn't an example
when I wasn't missing information.
And the parents say, we need to relay
information back and forth.
So the parents, who aren't medical experts,
are trying to figure out
what's important to tell people.
We wanted to see if the system
could help with that.
So here's what shared plans
would tell you about this setting.
First, if they're going to
reach consensus on the recipe,
then we could provide
support for people
not just making up a care plan
on a piece of paper
that they put in a drawer
or the electronic equivalent,
but something that's dynamic and active.
That in fact takes into account
that as the child's condition changes,
the plans evolve.
We could support communication
and coordination at the appropriate levels.
So figuring out who needs
to know what, when.
In order to do this, we have to solve
a really hard information sharing challenge,
which is to figure out
who needs to know
what when you don't have
the complete plan information.
So not only don't you, it's not only
that you don't know
exactly what
somebody else is doing,
so the PCP doesn't know exactly
what the GI doctor is doing,
nor does the physical therapist,
but you may not even know
the full set of plans.
You may not even have the probabilistic
recipe tree with a probability over them.
OK.
So what Ofra did was to look
at this loosely coupled nature
and recognize
that it was complemented
by the extended duration
of the work that people were doing.
So it's not one-shot deals,
and you can take advantage of that
to learn collaboration
patterns over time.
And from those collaboration patterns,
you can learn about task dependencies
and task allocation,
and you can reason
about information
sharing based on those learned
collaboration patterns.
Well, this need is not only in healthcare,
but also in various kinds of office work.
For example, when we
write papers with each other, how many of you
when you're writing
papers with three
or four other people are sending e-mail
and making phone calls
and getting together?
Right?
As wonderful as track changes
is in Google Docs.
So what she did was
to implement the mutual influence
potential representation in the MIP DOI algorithm
for collaborative writing;
compared giving all changes,
which is what systems today do,
with randomly filtering out some
so you have a smaller load,
with personalized filtering
based on the MIP DOI algorithm.
The results, very briefly,
were that not surprisingly,
if you limit the number of edits
you show people
they're more productive,
because they're looking
at fewer things.
If you base the change, so this is
what's important about the algorithm.
If you base the change on what
you've detected about interactions
between the work
that people are doing,
then it's judged more helpful
by the writers
and independently the results
are judged higher
quality by people
looking at what comes out.
So this personalized change
awareness makes a difference.
I'll just note here that this work
was really a wonderful blend of AI
and HCI, and I think we're at a time
in the development of both fields
where it's crucial for them
to work together.
They split apart a long time ago,
and it's really important to come together.
So now I want to take a step back
and actually look at
some of the lessons
from the research
that I've done over many decades.
And as a way of just summarizing
where we are with respect to this collaborative work
and also leading into some
discussion of dialogues,
because there's so much
going on in the dialogue
and language world these days.
So the first thing, so I actually got
into collaboration by doing research on dialogue.
The first thing was that we noticed
that dialogues aren't linear sequences,
they aren't random collections,
they're actually structured,
and you'll see an example
in a minute.
And the language that we speak
indicates the boundaries
and indicates
discourse information.
At the root of this structuring
of language is the intentions,
the purposes of the people
having the conversation.
And this is maybe the most important lesson
for those of you who are working on dialogue systems.
It's not just
the streams of words.
It is the underlying purposes you need to understand
to really participate in a dialogue.
OK.
We then moved in trying to,
Candy Sidner and I,
in trying to move
from understanding
this to understanding
how to model
those intentions.
And that's when I became
interested in collaboration,
because you can't represent
intentional structure
as plans of individual agents.
You have to, and that's where
shared plans came from.
And then there was a lot of,
we did it for dialogue
and then a mathematician friend
of mine said to me,
come on, two, do N.
And it turns out as any basketball coach
will tell you, N is a lot harder than two.
I think there's a big challenge here
at the edge already with this work,
which is how to integrate
the principles
from shared plans
for dialogue and collaboration
in a way that melds
with the data driven
ML approaches.
How are we going to bring
these two together?
Finally, from the collaboration
to loosely coupled plans,
I told you about
that research.
There is here also a challenge,
which is how do we do a broader challenge?
How do we deal with all
the different kinds of teamwork
and coordination
which have widely
different information-sharing circumstances?
And now, before I move
on to the next thing I want to talk about,
which is the ethics
aspect of all of this,
I want to read a quote
from Zak Kohane who is very,
very active in health informatics
and a big advocate
of using AI to understand
and support diagnosis.
He has a mother who has a cardiac issue,
and he was interviewed about this.
He said that on the one hand
it's really great to collect data
and use AI for that.
On the other hand,
there are family and friends.
And here's the quote.
"AI may be good at chess and go,
and developing expertise
once reserved for doctors
in arcane areas
such as reading X-rays."
Radiologists might disagree
about it being arcane,
but anyway.
"But AI does not do well at understanding
the wide world,
at picking up mood
or subtle signs of distress,
at convincing a resistant human
to listen to the doctor.
We don't need AI for that.
We need a caring village."
So again, an argument
for the complementarity of AI,
building systems
that complement us
rather than thinking about systems
that replace us
or simply replicate us.
So now I want to turn to look
at the question of ethics.
And I'm going to do that via an example
of a child's toy and dialogue.
Because as I said in the beginning,
AI is out there in the world.
We're using it all the time on phones
and for search and in many other ways,
and it's even now
entering toys for children.
And I think that really highlights
the importance of anyone
building a system
with any AI in it.
Frankly I think anyone
building a computer system that people are going to use
for anything other than programming need
to take into account.
So this is for those of you who didn't see
this article in the fall of 2015.
Mattel announced a new Barbie
doll that could talk,
and Mattel advertised
it as your daughter's
new best friend.
Here's an example dialogue
taken from the New York Times.
I teach a course on intelligent systems
design and ethical challenges.
And the students in the course
bought a Barbie doll,
and found the 300 pages
of scripts
that the Barbie doll follows.
So there are many more examples
that are even worse than this,
but we'll deal with this.
So Barbie knows this kid has a sister,
and asks, what nice things does she do for you?
The child says nothing.
Barbie says, what's
the last nice thing?
OK, Barbie hasn't
understood the word nothing.
Not in the script.
It's this little word, negatives are hard,
anyone who studies natural language knows that.
OK.
The child tries to answer,
but it's got another kind of negative word.
Destroyed it.
Barbie says, oh yeah.
Tell me more.
The kid gets a little annoyed.
I left that part out.
More than a little annoyed.
And Barbie says, have you told
your sister lately how cool she is?
At this point, I believe
the child said, that's it Barbie.
I forgot that part.
OK.
So here's the thing.
This is not just awkward but it raises,
I mean this is kind of funny for us,
but the whole idea
of having these kinds
of interchanges
with a kid raises
some ethical concerns.
And I'm just going to talk
about two of them, there were many more.
One is expectations that are violated
with respect to dialogue behavior,
and the fact that this doll
as my philosophy student
PhD student
teaching fellow said,
unremittingly pleasant,
like no human being
I've ever met.
Kind of this emotional
equivalent of being too skinny.
OK.
So language learning.
The doll is designed for three
to eight-year-old children.
They're supposed to be learning language
and how we have carry-on dialogues.
What they're learning is you
just ignore what the other person says,
and go along with
what you're saying.
This is not exactly what we would like to
teach three to eight-year-old children, boys or girls.
How about child development and friendship?
So unremittingly pleasant.
How many of you are unremittingly pleasant?
I didn't think so.
Thank you for being honest.
You know, we don't want a three-year-old
to think she has to be unremittingly pleasant.
On the other hand, we do want a child
to know that there's a penalty to pay
if you're mean to somebody,
and Barbie doesn't care
what the child says.
It just goes along with its script.
I'll just make a note here that I have
some worries about anybody
who thinks we should create
the Westworld environment,
given that most of us
would stop somebody
beating a dog on the street.
Why do we want to teach people that it's OK
to do what goes on in Westworld?
I don't know.
Anyway.
All right, so there are other questions.
Questions about trust and creativity,
but I won't be able to go into those.
OK.
You can ask me about them later.
OK so it's not just Barbie.
It's any approach to dialogue
that misses some of the key facts
we know about human dialogue.
And one of those is that dialogues
are structured by purpose.
They're not just linear sequences.
So here's one of my favorite examples
of why that matters.
Most of us were taught
that a pronoun referred to the last thing
that it matched in number and gender.
The last thing that them in blue matches
is number and gender is kids.
How many of you think that what
this person means is that they put the kids away?
How many of you, I just have to see
if you can raise your hands.
How many of you think
it's something else?
OK.
So here's what actually
went on in this dialogue.
There was some intonation.
John came by and left the groceries. Stop
that you kids. And I put them away after he left.
There's no question you didn't have
a question about what's going on.
Now this is a narrative
about groceries.
I have to say I was in the airport
on Saturday, my plane looked like it would be canceled.
I called the MSR travel people.
I could have had exactly the same conversation
but with it being about travel interrupted,
by saying something
to the noisy kids
who were unhappy their plane
might be canceled.
OK.
So finally, dialogue
is not just adjacency pairs.
It's Twitter conversations aside,
but you know, they have their limitations.
It's not just
question-response pairs.
So just from looking at this, you can see some of
the challenges for chat bots.
Open domains are going to be harder
than closed domains because you have to deal with many
more kinds of purposes.
Short dialogues that look just
like question-answer pairs are much easier
than when you get
into a real dialogue.
OK.
What are the roots
of the ethical challenges here?
Well we already saw
missing dialogue capabilities.
It's also the case that if you
give people something,
if they think a system can do one thing,
they will generalize to its
being able to do another.
So the last time I asked my phone
where the nearest E.R.
was, I did this, I gave a bunch of talks for phi
beta kappa traveling around the country.
It always could told me
where the nearest E.R.
was.
When I asked where I can get a flu shot,
it understood what I said,
but this is answer gave me.
Actually two different answers.
I don't know why I can't figure this out.
More importantly, when I asked
where can I go to get a sprained ankle treated,
this is the answer I got.
Now it's not so bad, really, to tell me
how to treat the sprained ankle.
But it would have been really bad
if this had been about a heart attack.
OK.
So we need to get it right.
We need to be clear about what
the competence is and what it's not.
And we need to take seriously this idea
that we can't build systems that commit
to doing something
they're not capable of doing.
But there are many other
ethical challenges that come up,
and they affect us
not just as individuals,
but they can affect
whole communities,
they can affect
the world at large.
And I have just some of them here
that I hope people will think about.
Privacy and security
is always brought up, but there's also a place
where there's a clash of the incentives
for business and social good.
And I'm really glad to see things
like the ETHER effort here at Microsoft
and the Partnership for AI,
because it's really crucial
that companies think about this.
So we saw this clash in the concern
for getting more clicks
and selling more ads
in the spread of fake news.
There are also questions of justice,
and Eric brought up some of this
in his talk about bias.
If you're predicting the future
based on the past, at the same time
that you're trying
to change communities
and lower crime,
for example,
then there's a clash between
this progressive cultural change
you want and the predictions
that you're making.
Also, and this came up in a
State Department workshop I chaired last fall.
There's great concern
about who owns the data.
And here we have data, it is not
just Google and Facebook,
by the way, it's the cars
that people are driving.
Who owns that data?
How is it going to be shared?
Who's going to determine
what regulations there are?
And then there are questions of equality,
and making sure that the benefits of the AI systems
we develop
are spread around the world
and of building trust.
Well, there's a much longer list.
The second thing I want to say is that
when you think about AI and ethics,
we should think not only
about not doing harm,
which is really important,
but about doing good.
And there was recently a AAAI
spring symposium in which people talked about many,
many different areas
including health care,
including sustainability.
I was glad to learn that
MSR has an effort on AI for Earth.
And so I think we really could all be thinking about,
there's just many, many aspects of life
where we could be building systems
that would be doing good,
and not just worry about
what we shouldn't be building.
OK, so then one of the issues
that people think about a lot,
and I think we as AI people
should think about
as computer scientists, by the way.
I don't think this is just an AI problem.
It's a problem of all the technology
that we're building.
It is about jobs, and about whether
we're replacing people,
augmenting people or complementing people.
So let me just give an example
from the legal and policy arena,
where we can think about things
that already computers
are really great at,
like document retrieval and search.
Things that they can do adequately
and well enough in some areas
like drafting straightforward documents.
And things that at least, in the near-term future,
they're unlikely to do well,
like producing a new persuasive
foreign policy initiative.
So that's the law environment,
the policy environment.
Health care is similarly nuanced,
as is education.
So the idea that we're going
to replace doctors.
Rather than thinking about how we can
replace them to save money,
we could think about how to build systems
that will enable them
to do their jobs more effectively,
just as we were doing with the teachers
in the examples I gave you.
OK.
So these are all high level things.
I think there's some things that as AI people,
as technology people, as computer scientists,
we should be thinking
about right now
because these are things
we can directly control.
We can't control foreign policy.
And that's the question of the jobs now,
not just in the future.
And here I've just given you two examples,
one is crowd-sourced piecework.
OK, so people working,
under what conditions?
Who regulates those conditions and how?
The second thing is as we think about designing systems
that have some AI capabilities, we could think about,
and we would think about them
as complementing people
rather than mostly replacing people.
And when they can't do it they just fail,
and then some poor person has to take over
and make up for their failures,
which happens to me all the time
when I get an automated
customer care agent.
We might think about figuring out a way
to build a system that would help,
let's say those customer care agents
do their jobs better.
So I would like people to think about that,
because I think we can do better
than we have done so far.
So far we have thought about, wow, could we replace
the person, OK if it fails it goes to the person.
That makes the person's job one of handling,
trying to figure out what the other person,
really the person who called in really wanted,
and how to make them happy now
that they're extremely unhappy.
Rather than enabling a person
to establish a relationship with somebody,
and then get them
an answer more quickly.
So let me turn to some general
ethical principles.
People have asked about who should decide the values,
and I think that's a really important thing
to leave with people, not machines.
I also want to urge people to stop thinking
about and help those of us
who are already working
with the press and others,
to get them to stop thinking
about robots taking over,
because it's not happening anytime soon
and it's a distraction from issues
that are important now.
So I personally think we have more to fear
from dumb systems that somebody has told us are smart,
than from intelligent systems
that know their limits.
And I know that Eric talked earlier
about unknowns and known unknowns.
I think this is really a system,
a really important thing to aim
for is a system that knows its limits.
So there are different ways for handling
the ethical challenges that come up.
The one we hear about most
is regulation and policy.
There's also design.
We can design the systems differently,
and that's really the main message
I want people to take away from here,
is that we can design systems differently.
One of the things that many people
are thinking about is,
could we build in ethical reasoning capabilities?
And that would be great, but it's hard enough
to build in reasoning capabilities,
so I think this is a long term aspiration.
Certainly an interesting research area,
but I'd like to see us focus on design right now.
And finally, when we put systems
out in the world,
we could accurately describe
their capabilities.
Mattel should not have said the Barbie doll
was going to be your daughter's next best friend.
OK.
So I'm actually unclear whether this is
my time or the total time.
OK.
- That's the total time.
But we'll make it work.
- OK.
All right.
So let me, this is my last major point.
I said earlier that teamwork capabilities had
to be designed in from the start.
Ethics also has to be
designed in from the start.
And to get it right in the future,
we need to do two things.
One is those of us who teach need
to integrate ethics into our curriculum.
We're doing this at Harvard now.
We experimented this past spring with having
a small ethics module in four courses.
We're going to do six in the fall.
A quick example from my class.
They study the Facebook emotion
contagion experiment on a Tuesday.
Lots of discussion of ethics,
by the way.
These students, 150 students
applied for a class of 30,
so they really wanted to get in
and they cared about ethics.
Forty-eight hours later on Thursday,
I gave an assignment and I did an in-class activity
on designing
a recommender system,
including needing to list
the characteristics
of the users they would collect.
After they reported out,
I asked how many of them
had thought about the ethical consequences
of the information
they were collecting.
None of them, none.
Well actually, this year one.
Last year, none.
If we're focused on efficient,
effective design with all this stuff,
you know efficient code, et cetera,
et cetera and ethics
isn't on the list,
it ain't going to happen.
So that's the second part.
Companies building systems need to make ethics
part of the product design.
OK.
I will end by saying it's not smart
if it doesn't work with us,
and we want it
pulling together,
not pulling against us.
I want systems that make us
feel smarter, not dumber.
And conjectures are really important.
Anybody who is early stage
and wants to know
how Chomsky
and McCarthy
discouraged me,
can ask me later.
They told me what I was
doing was impossible or useless.
And when we first did shared plans,
people told us to think harder
and we could do it
as individual plans.
So if you're young and you
have a good idea, go with it.
We need people to take risks now.
Computers aren't islands.
We've got to do this.
These are all the people
that helped me, including the funders.
And I'm happy for questions.
- Thank you, Barbara.
We have time for a few questions.
There are people running
around with a paddle,
so if you have a question,
please raise your hand.
And please say who you are and where you're from.
- Hi.
Brent, I'm from UC Berkeley.
- Wait, wait.
Where are you?
I didn't even call on anyone yet.
- Over here.
- OK.
- Paddle 3.
- Hi, I'm from UC Berkeley.
Thanks for the wonderful talk.
I had a question about foundations for teamwork.
You talked about how designing it from the start
is really critical for success.
How do these other, higher order,
social activities build into that foundation?
What is sort of the status today?
Things like competition, justice.
You mentioned ethics a little bit.
How does that factor in?
- Well, that's for people here and their students
and post docs to start working on.
Number one over there.
- Hi.
My name is Richard Banks.
I run the design team in Microsoft
Cambridge Lab,
and I spent a long time
with design students particularly
in the interaction design discipline.
And I'm wondering, what way do you think
we should be educating these students
who will be forming
the design part
of a multi-disciplinary teams,
in terms of both understanding AI
as a technology,
and starting to deal
with some of the ethical issues
that you were describing?
- That's terrific.
And I can tell you best by telling you
a bit about my course,
which is that it's aimed at students
who have had one programming course.
I co-teach it with somebody who is either
a philosophy graduate student or next,
this coming year,
actually a philosophy faculty member.
I think it's really, really important to have somebody
who has deep expertise in ethics there with you.
Almost, and let me tell you about what
we did at Harvard in the spring.
We had a recent PhD in ethics meet with faculty
to talk about the systems, the courses,
and what they were teaching and then
find a particular example
where ethics mattered.
So for example, in the HCI class,
they looked at accessibility.
Many apps are not accessible
to people who are blind or deaf,
so that was an issue
that they talked about.
Needless to say, in social
networking, they talked about fake news.
So you can find, that's what
I would recommend.
There have got to be a lot of good
people who are philosophers
and who have written,
who have studied ethics.
In fact, the Trolley problem
comes out of Britain, by the way.
And really, so make it
an integrated part of the design
that they're doing and the projects
that they're working on,
but bring it.
So I'm a disbeliever in professional ethics.
I think that's if you follow these rules,
you won't get sued.
You really, really have to go deeply
to become a thinker about ethical issues.
- OK, thanks.
Number two.
- Hi, Gershon Dublon from MIT Media Lab.
So one of the last things you said was we
need systems that make us feel smart.
And I wondered if you could comment
on this question of kind of,
how long it should take
to learn to use the system?
How easy should they be?
And I ask that because I mean,
teamwork as an example,
is not something that is
necessarily something that
we're well-suited for at the outset.
We learn to work together
over long periods of time.
And as we build these AI systems, what if it takes
two years to learn how to work with them?
How should we kind of think about that question?
- OK.
So first on systems in general,
I'll just quote Don Norman,
who said for those of you not in HCI,
a really important person
in the HCI community.
He said, I don't need a manual to use my toaster.
Of course that might not be true anymore.
So, it's true that as people we need
to learn with respect to each team
how to work with those team members.
I think it should take no longer to learn
how to work with a team computer agents
than it takes
to learn with each other,
and that depends on the people and whether they've,
how much they've been parts
of teams before or not.
But the systems, I think we should design
to be the best of team players.
- OK, thanks.
The last two questions
have been from Cambridge, and continuing that trend,
I think question number three was
from Cambridge as well.
No more Cambridge
questions after this.
- Hi.
Other Cambridge, David Karger, MIT.
- Hi David.
- Hi.
And I guess alumnus of your 1988 AI class.
So you talked about the sort of foundational
principles of collaboration,
your theory of collaboration and such.
It struck me as interesting
because you talked about sort of the need
for consensus around goals
and shared plans
and things.
One of your colleagues, Madu Sudan,
did some really interesting work a few years ago
on communication
with aliens,
and sort of developed a theory about
how you could actually
carry out communication
and say the communication
was happening,
even when the two parties
had no shared goals,
no shared understanding
of the universe.
And I'm wondering whether that sort of,
you know, how that relates to your arguments
that you have to have
these consensus goals?
And bringing it closer to home,
if you think about user studies,
where subjects are often not aware
of what they're doing,
or are even deceived
about what their goals are.
How does that play into
what you were talking about?
- So, remember what I said is
if the principles are violated,
you don't have real teamwork.
So the answer with Madu is to do it justice,
is much longer,
but he and I actually disagree on
when you have communication and dialogue.
So, and I would have to look at the user studies
to give you a particular answer,
but it's not saying,
you can have things
that look like teamwork
happen accidentally.
But if you don't have these conditions,
I can take that group of people
and whatever they're trying to do
and give you an example
where it would fall apart
and they would fail.
So that's the point of the principles.
It's not that you can't. Like you can have a system
that looks like, remember my point about errors?
You can have a system that looks like it's smart
until it looks like it's really dumb.
So you can have something that looks like
it's working like teamwork, and then it falls apart.
I can give you an example from the 1990s at Harvard.
I love this example.
Women Basketball.
The Ivy League always sends
one team to the NCAAs.
Harvard went.
Their first match was with Stanford,
because they were at the bottom
and Stanford was at the top.
Stanford's best player, I don't know,
tore her ACL or something.
Harvard won the game
and it was played at Stanford.
Why?
Because they had teamwork.
Ask their coach.
They could, Harvard could
lose their best player.
Stanford couldn't.
- OK, let's take one last question here.
Number two.
- Hi, Melanie Mitchell,
Portland State University.
- Hey.
You made the really great suggestion
that products that have AI in them,
like the Barbie example,
should advertise
their limitations.
- Yeah.
- But I'm wondering if you can comment
a little bit more on how feasible that actually is,
given that many of the systems
that seem to be the most successful
are the hardest to understand?
- So first, let me say that a system
knowing its own limits
is one of the hardest problems I know of.
With respect to the Barbie doll,
I'd like to get to the first step
of not being deceptive about
the capabilities that a system has.
And the designers know.
So I didn't say this with Barbie,
but it's one of my quips about it.
Most of us have known three-year-olds.
I don't know a single three-year-old
who follows a script.
I mean, does anybody?
If you do, raise your hand,
because I want to talk to you.
I know a lot of parents who would like
to know how this happened.
They always, OK.
We don't follow scripts.
That's why some of these
chat bots have trouble.
So I would just like them to say, look, this is a cute,
it's a, you know, for a normal kid
in a healthy environment
with great parents,
it probably doesn't matter.
The kid will throw it away after two days.
I would like to start with not
exaggerating the capabilities.
- OK.
Let's thank Barbara again
for her stimulating talk,
and she'll be around
for the next few days.